I want to talk a little bit about the
Mark Zuckerberg congressional testimony
I was very very interested to see
Facebook founder and CEO Mark Zuckerberg
testify before Congress but I am hugely
disappointed by what was effectively
kind of a joke of a hearing Facebook has
been in the middle of a major data
breach privacy concerns arguably the
biggest crisis for Facebook in their
history when you account sort of like
further current size and user base on
the platform
we learned that Trump's data mining firm
Cambridge analytic I got access to the
profile data of anywhere between 50 and
I've heard as high as 87 million users
cited Zuckerberg himself also admitted
that every Facebook user should assume
that their data was scraped by third
parties
it's truly bad right now even though as
I've said before every user should
always assume that their data was being
scraped in that way still a really big
PR disaster for Facebook so Mark
Zuckerberg shows up to testify before
Congress after it was sort of unclear
whether he was going to do it or not
whether he was going to send a deputy or
someone else from Facebook he shows up
and first of all and this is like a
general criticism of a lot of these
hearings it was kind of set up to lead
to nothing in the sense that Zephyr
Teachout wrote a good piece about this
in The Guardian and she pointed out each
questioner had five minutes which is not
uncommon no real follow-up questions not
uncommon each elected official just kind
of trying to get their questions on the
record one after the other Zuckerberg
was allowed to get away with total non
answers like for example he told Lindsey
Graham when Lindsey Graham asked is
Facebook a monopoly which maybe isn't
even the best question to be but it's
not it's sort of a broad question
Zuckerberg said I don't feel it doesn't
feel like Facebook is a monopoly okay
III don't know what we learned from that
and he was allowed to get away with that
Zuckerberg
basically did what anyone would do in
this format which is when you know that
each elected official has a bunch of
questions they want to ask you and they
have only five minutes he would answer
questions
broadly speaking about the mission of
Facebook and the philosophy of Facebook
and avoiding really answering the
questions and it's not a criticism of
Mark Zuckerberg specifically that is
often the case although when Bill Gates
testified it did seem to take sort of
different direction and it's not just
Zuckerberg or the format either because
even a lot of the questions that
Senators were asking were pointless
questions some about the philosophy of
Mark Zuckerberg and the technological
illiteracy of a lot of these questioners
made it so that they were asking
questions that were so basic that they
weren't going to get us anywhere at all
I mean remember Lindsey Graham we
covered this maybe about a year ago year
and a half ago Lindsey Graham admitted
not that long ago that he had never sent
an email in his life and he's supposed
to be questioning Mark Zuckerberg in a
serious manner Kamala Harris pressed
Zuckerberg to some degree but overall it
was a joke it was clueless elected
officials asking irrelevant or leading
or indirect questions to a guy who for
the most part was well-prepared to
filibuster and we really didn't learn
anything senator Orrin Hatch asked
Zuckerberg how do you sustain a business
model in which users don't pay for your
service and Mark Zuckerberg said we run
ads like really that's the level of
question that we're seeing at
congressional hearings with the founder
of Facebook so big picture I'd call it a
win for Zuckerberg he showed up he
didn't sustain real damage major failure
overall for consumers no real
revelations or a new path forward in
terms of fixing the problem here fixing
the problem that got Zuckerberg into the
room in the first place and there's one
other thing that also came of it a ton
of people online were sort of ridiculing
Mark Zuckerberg for his mannerisms and
his physical appearance and how he
talked and gesticulated
I know the guy's a multi-billionaire but
who cares right the these are not
arguments making fun of the guy's
demeanor and and sort of body language I
don't understand what the point of that
is I get it he's a public figure and
it's a huge stage of congressional
testimony but there's plenty of other
areas of concern I don't think how Mark
Zuckerberg talks or gesticulates is
really the top priority my actual bigger
bigger concern is number one regulations
sort of the if and what what sort of
regulation could even be put in place to
prevent what happened from happening
again and of course there's the cozy
relationship between companies like
Facebook and Amazon and others and our
elected officials I don't remember the
exact numbers but some significant
percentage of the people that were on
the panel questioning Mark Zuckerberg
had received campaign contributions from
Facebook and that gets us back to
campaign finance and really a broader
issue that needs to be dealt with at a
systemic level and there's no indication
that there's any appetite to deal with
that this was a sort of dog and pony
show where Mark Zuckerberg like most of
these folks was prepared to and did
filibuster the questioners had a number
of pre-written questions that I mean
obviously pre-written that's not a
criticism but questions that they had
just committed to kind of getting
through with no real follow up and zero
appetite at actually tackling what is
one of the biggest issues here which is
the way that elections are financed and
how companies like Zuckerberg are
putting money directly into the pockets
of the people that are supposed to be
overseeing what it is that the company
is doing and thinking about regulation
send me your thoughts do you think we
really learned anything from Mark
Zuckerberg testimony if so let me know
that testimony continues today maybe
today will go differently today's
program is made possible in part by
fruit or fruit or is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board from politics to
sports and everything in between
you wager on predictions about
world events using for tours in game
fake currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
and improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account
and follow me by clicking the link in
the description if you're watching this
on YouTube
this week on futur I pose the question
will there be a congressional hearing
regarding the Trump sexual assault
allegations what do you think click the
link in the description and place your
bets and you can browse the politics
category on futur to wager on other
predictions sign up now at root or calm
and start making your forecasts on
political topics and tons of other
topics totally free available on both
Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers that is fut you you are calm